[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
bienvenidos escala en París una emisión
de radio Francia internacional en
colaboración con la televisión France 24
en español en la que damos la palabra
artistas gente del mundo de las ciencias
las artes políticos diplomáticos y de la
sociedad civil México ha recuperado
estos últimos tres años más de 5000
piezas arqueológicas que por diversos
motivos muchas veces ilegales salieron
del país de ese total Barcelona
entregado más de 2000 piezas los Países
Bajos también Alemania en el seno de la
Unión Europea también devolvieron piezas
a México no obstante hay una excepción
al interior de la Unión Europea se trata
del gobierno francés que Hasta ahora ha
rechazado restituirle a México piezas
arqueológicas arqueológicas que
regularmente son subastadas aquí en
Francia para hablar de este tema así
como de otras políticas que está
llevando a cabo el gobierno del
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
tenemos y saludamos aquí en nuestro
estudio a Blanca Jiménez Cisneros
embajadora de México ante la República
francesa señor embajadora muy buenos
días buenas tardes con nosotros has
pasado bastante tiempo para lograr
finalmente esta entrevista por la
responsabilidad que usted tiene el
pasado mes de julio usted declaró que en
Francia es imposible impedir la venta de
arte precolombino por lo que preconiza
usted llevar a cabo una política de
concientización para evitar que
precisamente las casas de subastas o los
compradoras sigan llevando a cabo esta
política un poco de saqueo vamos a
decirlo claramente de las piezas
arqueológicas mexicanas y de otros
países qué tan eficaz es esta
planteamiento Sabiendo el pasado mes de
julio también hubo piezas arqueológicas
que fueron subastadas aquí en Francia Yo
creo que es un proceso en el cual
Tenemos que trabajar mucho en hacer este
cambio de mentalidad notamos que ya se
comienza a existir esta posibilidad de
hecho hemos tenido ya retornos
voluntarios de piezas de
gente que vive en Francia incluso una
cierta persona nos devolvió algo dijo
que por favor no diéramos un hombre y
era una condición y poco un poco estamos
comenzando a ver este cambio es un
cambio de paradigma es como hacer que la
gente ya no compre las pieles que antes
se veía muy bien era como pues muy un
signo de lujo porque así un poco son las
piezas es comenzar a concientizar a la
gente de la importancia que tienen este
tipo de obras para cierta para ciertas
civilización y yo creo que sí se puede
hacer así como tampoco ya no se compran
los jeans que deslavados porque
contaminan los ríos en otros países y
uno puede decir Bueno a un francés de
aquí que le afecta que hay un río
contaminado en otro país de la misma
manera si comienzan a entender la
relación que hay con estos objetos y con
el entender y el saber y la cultura y la
apreciación de la gente porque hay casos
en que se están vendiendo incluso
deidades de poblaciones que tiene un
significado muy profundo yo Considero
que la gente de Francia que es una gente
muy culta que le gusta viajar que le
reconoce mucho este tipo de valores es
capaz de cambiar ahora que también ver
de que la gente estamos hablando la
gente que compra en la subastas
exactamente que tiene recursos y que lo
va a privatizar claramente a este
propósito embajador a Colombia Guatemala
Honduras Perú y el propio México y
enviaron una carta hicieron público un
manifiesto el pasado mes de noviembre
sino mal recuerdo precisamente
planteando a las autoridades francesas
la necesidad de que tome medidas más
enérgicas más precisas para evitar
precisamente que se venda este tipo de
piezas ese mismo mes no obstante se
vendieron aquí por la casa christies 72
piezas de arqueología mexicana Sí pero
la carta tuvo mucho efecto en primer
lugar el efecto de ver ya a América
Latina unida de hecho se han Unido más
países a esta a esta solicitud
Panamá República Dominicana y Bolivia y
es Es que es algo que que ahorita
hablamos de América Latina Pero eso
también un problema que tienen países de
África que tiene países de Asia que de
muchos lados Yo creo que es es como un
clamor de decir nuestra como como
decimos también con nuestro patrimonio
no se vende es algo como cultural y un
poco a veces digo a ver qué es integrar
ustedes que viniéramos a subastar en
México la espada de Napoleón
Abraham se ve un poco diferente un poco
diferente por eso yo creo que es
entendernos un poco más y también hacer
ver es esta diferenciación que hay
Porque como digo Son ciertos países es
cierta clase social la que está metida
en este tipo de de esquemas y que se
podrían cambiar si se ven muy mal era
como la gente que compraba las pieles no
eh En el caso que hablamos es
precisamente el gobierno francés que
desde hace ya lustros que se le ha
estado pidiendo parar este tipo de
políticas y le da la prioridad al
derecho privado por encima de lo que
sería el patrimonio cultural yo siento
que también comienza a ver una apertura
también
un poco Como no me gusta ponerte a todos
y poner todo en un solo grupo de gente
por ejemplo las gentes en los museos
muchos de los museos de Francia que
lleva uno de los museos y hablan de la
exfoliación y hablan del origen de las
piezas y es un primer paso para comenzar
a cambiar el gobierno de Francia también
ha sido muy
consistente en el apoyo tenemos un
acuerdo firmado y estamos trabajando en
capacitación y en tratar de ver estos
cambios y yo creo que el reciente caso
que se está dando ahorita del caso de de
abu dhabi va a ser revisar Precisamente
lo que está planteando es revisar la
legislación y los mecanismos de trabajo
aquí en Francia de hecho sabemos que en
el senado ya está interesado en en
conocer por ejemplo el caso de México y
el caso de América Latina a este
propósito y tratándose precisamente de
piezas arqueológicas quiero trasladarme
ahora a México Vamos a hablar del tren
Maya uno de los megaproyectos más
ambiciosos del presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador que también ha causado no
poca polémica hay que recordar que el
tren Maya es un proyecto un megaproyecto
que abarca 500 kilómetros que comprende
cinco países y que tiene como objetivo
facilitar el turismo de esos 14 millones
de personas que regularmente cada año
visitan lo que se conoce como la Rivera
Maya señor embajadora no obstante Hay
que decir una cosa si hay un proyecto
que ha generado gran revuelo en México
gran oposición de cientos de miles de
personas de habitantes de especialistas
arqueológicos de economistas es
precisamente este tren Maya cómo
explicar lo que ellos llaman un
despropósito de la parte del gobierno de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador y que además
más avanza el proyecto más están
apareciendo casos de corrupción en la
construcción de ese proyecto yo creo que
lo podemos explicar Porque si bien Hay
100.000 personas como dice usted que
están en contra también hay varios
millones que están a favor del proyecto
hay que recordar que la parte sur de
México es una parte sumamente pobre
nunca se desarrolló y curiosamente
porque es una zona sumamente rica yo me
llama mucho la impresión cuando van
muchas gentes tu México dicen cómo es
posible que un país con tanta riqueza
siga teniendo tanta pobreza
lo mismo aunque es un poquito mejor las
las condiciones de vida hacia el norte
los salarios ganan ganan más y hacia el
sur había muy poco desarrollo es la
importancia del de este tren
Precisamente es combinar dos cosas un
proyecto social de desarrollo económico
Porque también se va a usar para mover
mercancía Pero hay muchas de las cosas
que hay que prácticamente no se venden y
lo que generan aparte de promover el
turismo y No únicamente como usted
menciona ahorita hacia el lado de este
la Rivera Maya que es lo que se conoce
hay muchas otras zonas de mucha
importancia que también podrían
conocerse por supuesto es muy importante
proteger todo lo que es la parte
ecológica porque es una zona por eso
mismo de que es muy rica aunque no
quiero decir que los desiertos daña que
protegerlos también Creo que tienen una
importancia ecológica estas son Es una
muy una zona muy rica tanto en fauna
como en Flora es muy importante tener
toda esta protección se hizo un cálculo
creo que se ha hablado poco de eso y
toda la zona que se va a abrir a abrir
que es poca porque ya había ahí un tren
había un trazado un tren ya hay líneas
de tren clásico Casi casi está siguiendo
todo lo mismo se abrió se abrió otra
zona otra área natural protegida hacia
hacia la zona de Guatemala
en por se me viene el nombre calagón
pero no escalafón toda esta zona se
abrió se duplicó el número de hectáreas
que se van a abrir en esta zona de zona
área protegida
una cosa de compensación entre otras
cosas lo que era un proyecto turístico
el pasado mes de julio ahora el
presidente ha decidido convertirlo en
una cuestión estratégica y de seguridad
nacional lo que evita que pase por el
por el parlamento cómo explicarte un
proyecto turístico ahora se convirtió en
una cosa de seguridad nacional bueno el
tema de que también tiene la situación
del tren Maya es
controlar un poco la migración la mayor
parte de los migrantes que van hacia
Estados Unidos vienen por parte del sur
de hecho una parte del tren maya va
incluso a surtir algunas ciudades de
América Central para tratar de controlar
esta parte de seguridad Yo creo que es
un tema así y no sé si está usted
recientemente ahí pero la cantidad de
migrantes de país es tremendos y este y
son gente no no no estamos hablando de
mexicanos hablamos hace ratito de otro
tipo de turismo pero la cantidad de
gente que hay de Haití de Panamá del
Salvador en México viviendo también
están poniendo canciones muy seguras y
la población también está bastante pero
la construcción de ese tren Maya
justamente no va elegir entre otras
cosas lo que usted dice hay gente que
llega ilegalmente sin papeles vamos a
decirlo ese tren Maya No va a facilitar
más precisamente la circulación de esas
agentes la idea del tren Maya es
incrementar las posibilidades de trabajo
y mejorar la economía local de manera de
ir fijando a la gente a la región yo
creo que una región más fuerte podría
ser más resiliente por eso también se
extendió hacia América Central de hecho
también se extendió otro programa que se
habla muy poco que es sembrando vida y
ya en México lo está haciendo en varios
países de América Central este Este es
un programa igual para arraigar a la
gente y se vio también como un tema de
de por ayudar a la gente pero también de
seguridad para nosotros para tratar de
ir arraigando estas cosas son problemas
bastante complicados embajadora hay otro
tema que llama la atención notablemente
aquí en Francia y no solo al interior de
la Unión Europea estamos ya en el cuarto
año de la administración del presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador el
presidente no ha puesto una sola vez un
pie de la Unión Europea cuando que se
trata de un socio comercial fundamental
Incluso estratégico el acuerdo comercial
firmado con la Unión Europea habla
también un proyecto estratégico él Pudo
ver al presidente Donald Trump
qué es lo que lleva que hay este
descuido de las relaciones con la Unión
Europea de la parte del presidente bueno
porque nuestro canciller es sumamente
activo
la personalidad jerárgicamente fueran
distintamente sin duda Aunque en las
relaciones con Francia no que estuvieron
mejores que con este canciller ahora han
sido excelentes el tema es que el
presidente dice ahorita dedicar su
tiempo principalmente a las cuestiones
de México y es una cosa que les ocupa Yo
creo que es muy muy difícil entender
para la gente el ritmo de trabajo que
tiene el presidente diario empieza a las
6 de la mañana y la verdad que yo estaba
en esas reuniones un día llega a las 6
de la mañana y estaban todos empezados a
empezar a las 6 No aquí hay que llegar
al mente para las 6 porque empieza a
lograr que se despierta de seis en la
mañana a las 7 da conferencia de prensa
trabaja todo el día y los fines de
semana hace recorridos eso le permite
muy poco distraerse hacia afuera y lo
que quiero ahorita es con consolidar
hacia adentro para comenzar a atender
afuera yo no sé si vaya a salir a Europa
ya salió Estados Unidos había dicho que
no iba a salir a Estados Unidos y ya
salió podría ser pues Lamentablemente se
nos va el tiempo rápidamente nos quedan
miles de preguntas para tratar con usted
en cualquier caso le agradezco a usted
embajadora de México aquí en Francia su
presencia Blanca Jiménez Cisneros
Muchísimas gracias muchas gracias por la
entrevista a ustedes les damos una
próxima cita aquí la otra semana en otra
escala en París
[Música]
[Aplausos]